issued in Florida between Disney and
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis is now
headed to court the company has filed a
First Amendment lawsuit against DeSantis
a potential GOP Presidential candidate
did so yesterday alleging he has led
quote a targeted campaign of government
retaliation close quote against Disney
ever since Disney publicly criticized
the state's so-called don't say gay Bill
last March Manuel horkas has more
Disney's lawsuit was filed just minutes
after a board appointed by Governor Ron
DeSantis nullified Provisions that
allowed the company to largely govern
the land around Disney World in its suit
Disney calls the board's decision
patently retaliatory patently
anti-business and patently
unconstitutional DeSantis has called
Disney's opposition to the law out of
line and while on a visit to Israel this
morning addressed the suit they're upset
because they're actually having to live
by the same rules as everybody else they
don't want to have to pay the same taxes
as everybody else and they want to be
able to control things without proper
oversight the feud goes back to March of
last year when Disney spoke out against
the state's parental rights and
education law
which bans lessons relating to sexual
orientation and gender identity in
Florida classrooms
controversial law which previously only
applied to grades k-3 was expanded in
recent weeks through the 12th grade in
Florida gender ideology has no place in
our schools and if that means taking on
Disney to make sure that's the case we
will do it
this is a lot about his image and how
he's uh perceived Republican primary
voters and they feel like this helps
them GOP political consultant Terry
Sullivan doesn't see DeSantis backing
down as the governor weighs a potential
2024 presidential campaign but if he
were to want to get to general election
and actually gets there what does it
mean at that point you know you cross
that bridge when you come to It Disney
is a heavy economic hitter in Florida
it's the largest taxpayer in the state
employs more than 75 000 people there
and is a major driver of Tourism the
company projects it will draw around 50
million visitors to Florida this year
in comments at Disney's shareholder
meeting earlier this month CEO Bob Iger
appeared to foreshadow the lawsuit a
company has a right to freedom of speech
just like individuals do the governor
got very angry about the position Disney
took and seems like he's decided to
retaliate against us I think there is
something there to Disney's argument CBS
News legal contributor Jessica Levinson
acknowledged desantis's claim that his
administration is simply treating Disney
as all other businesses in the state are
treated but she added this it seemed
like everything was fine in terms of how
Disney was being treated until they
started criticizing the government
that's where you get that freedom of
speech claim for CBS mornings I'm Manuel
beforecas
[Music]